prende tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo in un
nuovo logo
non so di parlare sono arrivate due
miliardi di mail perché lo stato non è
uscito il blog perché era natale più o
meno mi si stavo stavo coi parenti favi
non hai fatto il blog sito arriva in
testa
e siccome passato natale ho passato
anche un po di tempo con la mia famiglia
è successo e succede una volta al secolo
però calmi mi chiave non è possibile
comunque blog si è salvato ed e uscito
ok prima di cominciare ad iniziare con
la panne d'arte la settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da mokart che
gesù sango non è così allora questa
ragazzi questa è la foto resta è la
[ __ ] foto questa è la [ __ ] fan art
come è possibile questa cosa nella vita
propria veramente faccio di disegni da
cani modulo disegnato io quello dello
scorso per farvi capire mi sono anche
impegnato non ci posso credere che un
disegno veramente sei un fenomeno
complimenti comunque ragazzi detto
questo linee di passare alle news la
scorsa settimana sono usciti due
speciali e spero che vi siano piaciuti
lega perché ho mai fatto nessuno di
questi due speciali che ho fatto e tra
pochissimo ragazzi uscirà anche il terzo
speciale che vi avevo promesso niente
spero che vi piaccia ragazzi comunque ho
notato che siccome non facciamo momenti
epici da tipo mesi 2 miliardi di clip
epiche da da parte quindi posso farne 12
divido epici così quindi ragazzi
aspettatevi un casino di speciali da
versione avanti comunque e l'altra news
che vi voleva dire ragazzi che stanno
uscendo i giochi per la con lo slip
quello nuovo che i ragazzi adesso in
avanti più avanti in generale vedete sto
cavo che nervi ma vedete che io devo non
sodomizza il cavo hashtag vio avanti
farò un faro dei video anche con la
consip nuovo e non vedo l'ora di vedere
con me perché non occorre neanche
provato voglio provare a privata
registrando quindi sarà una figata
assurda ha detto questo ragazzo è finito
con le news ed è un miracolo perché di
solito vi tartassi maroni per 12 ore di
passare allo scartando dei pacchi che ai
ragazzi avevo visto stoppa che ho visto
che ci aveva un cuoricino e poi ho visto
tutto quanto il resto e mi sono fatto
due domande nel mondo che vorrei c'è
solo farvi geri e questa epica ti
ringrazio ma la domanda che volevo farmi
che mi sono già fatto un casino di volte
ma mela rifarò ogni [ __ ] volta perché
non è possibile colui che
intanto questo palco imposta se stai
guardando questo video mi deve scrivere
nei commenti ma cosa tu cosa hai pensato
come prima cosa est e troppo strano è
una scatola riciclata di amazon
bellissimi ragazzi e ripartire dal primo
che il più piccolo come al solito di
vedere se gli alpha vj fa vj valigie non
si capisce che per me è stoppa con non
l'avrei mai detto proprio anzitutto
ragazzi il disegno e belli complimenti
per il disegno vedere cos'è sta roba
cos'è cos'è una delle cose più belle che
abbia mai visto però mi fa paura
evitiamo sei un mito da fili paganti
ringrazio non avessi intanto c'è una
calligrafia della madonna complimenti
veramente se fossi abbrevia in pippo ma
filippazzi abbreviando va beh come
ultimo ragazzi il fa vj book cosa è
stata o mio dio e per i mente qua dentro
ci scrivo nel mio diario è una roba
fanta oppure a muore qualcuno se scrivo
sono ne frega no non ci credo non puoi
riciclare le scatole di zalando e
mandarne le riprende ti supplico non
vado a consegnarla qualcuno gli urla in
faccia mi cita occulta pubblicità al
punto ovunque pubblicità occulte
illuminati con che ragazzi non penso che
ci trovi delle scarpe code credo di nord
che per così sarò ma ci sono delle delle
pantofole col mio nome
ok mi hai regalato della adesso mele
mette voglio vedere come mi stanno mica
che cosa egocentrica che azzeccato il
mio numero non so com'è possibile siete
pronti ad assistere alla sec saggine
[Musica]
oh yeah fucking sexy lunghi ragazzi a
parte il le pantofole troppo sexy mi
avete inviato anche il profumo non c'è
armani non c'è per crampi che tenga
perché questo questo è il profumo di
peppa pig cioè una roba tipo massa di
maiale sta roba profumo più di prima
tanto ragazzo trova cos'è sta roba o mio
dio c'è secondo te io metto questa roba
in giro dopo di che i ragazzi ho trovato
cos'è questo calze da donna da mettere
sì perché io metto queste cose è come
ultimo un orsacchiotto con una tazzina
che è troppo filo a chia ragazzi ci
siamo per questo devo ancora capire che
cos'è
ho trovato così no fermi ma dio mi ama
ci metti un cadavere qua dentro è una
banana pupazzo quanto sei figo ma è la
cosa più bella che abbia mai visto
quante quante cose a sfondo sessuale ci
sono in questo blog guarda se sei una
femmina credo che ti chiamerò filippa
proprio benvenuto così ecco i ragazzi
del pacco trovato una banana che è tipo
tutto un doppio senso prova benedetto
queste ragazzine che possiamo passare
alfano risponde prima di cominciare la
ragazza voleva dirvi che nell'allora
quando ho fatto lo speciale quello delle
20 verità su di me avevo detto che ce
n'era una che non era vera tra quelle
venti che ho detto e abbiamo detto che
l'avrei detto nel blog quindi la dico
perché sono vi continuate a me mi
arrivano ancora domande che mi chiedono
quale era con la falsa dalle curiosità
forza ragazzi era quella della mia saga
preferita quindi mi ricordo il numero
avrò tipo avevo detto nella mia saga
preferita in assoluto la signore degli
anelli invece no è la seconda preferita
zione nellina prima harry potter molti
l'hanno azzeccata però molti hanno detto
altre cose tipo alcuni non ci credevano
che sono stato campione regionale di
freccette
giuro che è vero chiudo questa parentesi
perché ho giocato a chiedermelo me la
porto fino alla tomba perché indossando
questa roba
ma prima devo andare al gf vi risponde
ancora link vi prego fa che sia una cosa
non brutta o mio dio che cazzo che cosa
[ __ ] e quest'anno ma serio e io che
volevo comprarmi un pesce ragazzi la mia
vita è completa basta ma è come fate fa
è stranissimo no basterà più passerò la
giornata così sempre comunque meglio di
questo è
cosa cazzo appena guardato proprio non è
mai pedale alla gara da quando ho tirato
fuori la storia di bob che il ragazzo
senza braccia che ho disegnato io tra
l'altro mal di testa non sento tipo bob
non è mai felice perché se sei felice tu
lo sai batti le mani
che tristezza cosa ricevuto proprio per
natale un paio di guanti ma non è vero
deve ancora aprire regali è di una
tristezza il mondo storia di un miliardo
di messaggi così lo sa perdere povero
bob gates che poverino le braccia dai
batti il cinque zio prossima domanda poi
sfodera to fail parte di un piano alieno
o chip notiz
in più noi come cazzola iscritto i
primati zara in uno dei tuoi video e
diventeremo rotto esercito personale
sarà suddiviso è comandato da varie
persone cioè vari fa vj attento io ti
osservo c'è ma se mi passa per la testa
intanto veramente non capisco da sé
tutto cazzo tutto tutto idiota sensi
stai zitto si stato fatto niente
l'accordo ragazzine che posso concludere
qui con le domande la fa vi domandate
oggi ragazzi e da quanto mi seguiteli
preciso da quanti mesi giorni settimana
gari 1 sestito da cinque minuti ma
volevo più che altro vedere ragazzi la
diversità delle risposte mi ero curioso
di vedere questa cosa che un ragazzino e
che possono chiudere qui video cosa
sento seguito è piaciuto è stato
commento mi piace anche a faccia di
facebook e come noi vino trattenere
scrizione chelsea con i sedici metri ci
vediamo il prossimo video belle ragazze